hi I'm Rob Denham I'm from the IBM cloud
team and today I want to talk to you
about why you might want to use a
service mesh how the sto service mesh
works and some core concepts for you to
get started quickly let's use this
example application I have a UI micro
service talking to two versions of
catalog which talk to inventory all of
these are services deployed inside of a
kubernetes cluster the number one reason
why someone uses a service mesh is
because they want to secure their
workload so they want mutual TLS when
one service is talking to another next
they want to dynamically configure how
the services are connected to one
another so in this example there's
version 1 and version 2 so I might want
to send 90% of the traffic diversion one
and then 10% of the traffic diversion
two while I do testing and incremental
rollouts I might also want to try adding
retry policies and surkhi braking to
harden my system
3 I want to observe how my application
is doing end to end not just if a
service is up or down but see where the
bottlenecks are in the system and how
traffic is flowing and for I want to
control who has access to talk to what
and this example UI is allowed to talk
to catalog and catalog is allowed to
talk to inventory but UI is not allowed
to talk to inventory directly and rogue
containers cannot talk to inventory
service you can get more granular than
that and say that UI is allowed to make
an HTTP GET request and catalog is a lot
to make a post request inventory in the
past
we used to have our developers program
all of these features directly into
their application code that slowed down
the dev cycle it made these micro
services bigger and just generally made
everything less flexible but now there's
a better way and that's the service mesh
you keep your application small and
business focused and instead you
dynamically program the intelligence
into the into the network and that's
exactly what sto does so when you have
is still installed first thing you'll do
is it'll automatically inject proxies
next to each one of your containers and
these proxies are envoy proxies and the
proxy itself runs in a container
next to your application container but
it runs inside the same kubernetes pod
now when you I wants to talk to catalog
the proxy will actually intercept that
request apply any policies and then
route traffic to the proxy on the other
side and then the catalog proxy will
receive that request and then forward it
down to a catalog it still will
configure each one of these proxies with
your desired configuration its neo
extends kubernetes using C RDS so to
apply a steel configuration you just
write your llamo and then applied to
kubernetes the ischial galley component
will receive that llamo validated and
then hand it over to sto pilot pilot
will convert that configuration to envoy
configuration and distribute it to each
one of the proxies if you want the pout
the proxies to add additional policies
and roles there is a policy component
and then these proxies constantly report
telemetry information about what's going
on into your system to the sto telemetry
component and last but not least their
Citadel Citadel is responsible for
providing strong identity to eat one of
the services in your system it also
generates certificates and rolls it out
to each one of the proxies so that the
proxies can do mutual TLS when they're
talking to one another
to get started with this tio and to
configure sto there's three main
resources that you need to learn about
first there's a gateway gateway is like
a load balancer that sits at the edge of
your mesh and accepts incoming and
outgoing HTTP and TCP connections next
to direct traffic from Gateway to your
services you create a virtual service
and a virtual service can be bound to a
gateway and direct traffic to UI or it
could be bound to a service and then
direct traffic to your other services
where you can apply policies like 90%
and 10% traffic split rules once traffic
is routed you can apply rules on
top of that traffic such as TLS settings
or circuit braking and those are done
using destination rules and these done
those are the three main resources you
need to know about sto I'm actually
going to put policy and telemetry in
asterisks because there's some
refactoring that's going on with these
components the logic is being moved
outside of this control plane and into
the proxies themselves to avoid the
additional network hop this translates
to improved performance thanks for
watching this video if you want to see
more videos like this leave a comment
below and please like and subscribe